what's up reject nation gonna watch the
attack on Titan season 4 final season
official trailer I'm gonna do a screen
recording of the one on YouTube that way
there could be some subtitles included
here been going through a lot of
comments the past couple days I'm doing
my best to see what most people have
been requesting hope right now that
during this time everyone is doing their
best to be as safe as possible and doing
whatever they can to be as truly
informed and self educating on this
entire situation that's not just in
America now but is now pretty much
worldwide I would encourage you guys
that if anyone is out there who's
looking to engage in a peaceful protest
to make sure that it's an official one
just wanted to make sure to throw that
tidbit out there but anyway attack on
Titan in season four over a patreon uh I
actually did watch along sync up with
the timecode for all of attack on Titan
and the last half of season 3 had the
option for watch along and reaction
highlights included but a long time
since I've seen this show I mean a year
for me with the amount of lore and heavy
information has especially revealed in
the last few episodes of that series I'm
gonna do my best to recall as much as
possible when discussing this show post
reaction did want to shout out our
patreon page really quick because you
guys have been incredible to us over
there both John and I are doing our best
right now to ensure that while we can
sustain this channel and keep it alive
that we're also giving as much as we can
to charity and with any of our earnings
but over our patreon we have a weekly
Q&A podcast that we do three to four
times a month and then we also do TV
show reaction watch alongs and there are
several shows that have reaction
highlights included that we edit
ourselves and those shows are attack on
Titan JoJo's Bizarre Adventure so I just
finished the promised Neverland death
note my hero academia fully caught up on
that the two heroes movie included
almost done with Code Geass midway
through season 3 of Hunter hunter or
season a one-punch man Hall of Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood supernatural
and Doctor Who and then there are
several other shows where it's only
watch along shows like Gotham agents of
shield Amanda Laurie and there's
actually a whole bunch if you go on over
to our patreon page today that would be
amazing generally only plug the patreon
at the beginning of the month just as a
heads up
[Music]
her there's a different animation
company this year
more Batum Arlena whoa that guy snap oh
the war is really going on huh some new
faces here
whoa
oh yeah but stepping rider man oh my
goodness the last attack I gotta say
even though they've changed animators I
mean I've heard some of the same people
who were involved with doing the
animation for the first three seasons
that this still looks undeniably
beautiful and epic and sweeping camera
movements I heard this last season's
only gonna be 12 episodes long I haven't
read the Matt manga yeah so you know I
don't know how much condensing will go
into it and there are parts in here that
I couldn't fully tell what might be
present-day with the current wartime
like with Marley and LD ends what was
flashback material cuz there's a lot of
new faces now I've also heard that with
the animation as crazy looks in the
trailer that it's gonna look even better
when the actual show comes out because
they're gonna be enhancing it even more
in the meantime I think this is supposed
to come out in the fall very excited to
see this because like I said I haven't
read the manga so I really don't know
what's gonna happen I mean I know you
got the the war between the Marlins
thing cuz I used the LD ins and then of
course the fight for Paradise Island
you got the nine Titans here if you
don't know the show I'm not gonna try to
explain all the lower because honestly I
hike I simply can not I'm sure there's
other videos out there 100% confident
there's other videos out there that'll
do a great job of breaking down all the
Lord me but it's like just skimming
these images I don't know who this tide
it is this one with all the the complete
white Titan looks crazy to me and then
there's like some other images that
stand out like I mean you got this image
here would like some spinal like
tentacle thing that kind of looks like
this could be linking to the origin of
you Mir here and maybe this does - I'm
not a hundred percent sure obviously you
know like we got a big breakdown of the
basic history of yamir and Fritz all
that with them with Marley and then
Paradise Island what led to all that I'm
under the impression that this season
will probably go a lot more into detail
with the full origin of yamir how she
came into the possession of the founding
Titan and all the actual nitty gritty
detail
as opposed to just quick explanation
breakdown so I'm excited to really learn
that not that we got all the information
we did get at the last half of season
three now I'm really hoping we can do a
full-on dive in the way how we did with
grisha's history that we can do that
with yamir and really seeing a lot more
in depth of the evolution of what led us
to this point and all honestly like the
action in the show is some of the best
i've ever seen ever in all forms of
media so the fact that we're getting
like the rest of the other Titans of the
nine I'm just excited to see what or
that has in store and also how that
wrapped you know just what's sweeping
action animation we have I have no clue
how this is going to conclude and we got
so much information with like Zeke being
the half-brother of Aaron but Aaron has
you know the possession of the attacked
ID and the power is the founding tide
and within him so it seems like it's
going down a path Aaron will be the
ultimate savior for all of this but this
is anime and I had around the manga so
things could end in a very very bleak
way I'm hoping they don't because this
show is so bleak already that it would
be nice for this to end on a beautiful
note the way how they got to the
coastline at the end of season three if
they could have a bit of a note like
that in the end maybe not a full-on
conclusion because I imagine they're
gonna be doing a lot of time jumps I
mean even the end of season three had a
six-month time jump and this is gonna be
12 episodes so while we're cutting
between present and past presumably I
think we'll probably see a time jump in
towards the end of the show that will
show us the the conclusion and the path
that we're on right now give me this
trailer I did I thought this would this
is a knee and like the Crist crystal
Chris chrysalis I think it's things
chrysalis is the right word so she's
coming back she's just been cocooning
this whole time this is just such a very
special show there's always so much
breaks in between and the fact that the
pandemic also going on doesn't do the
show any favors in terms of getting an
earlier release date or something like
that so I'm pretty sure they're sticking
to the fall for when this show will be
coming out there's a lot riding on this
this is the final season it should be a
very tight considering that it's only
four seasons the last season only being
12 episodes and this could go down in
history if they play their cards right
with how consistent this show has been
if kids could go down in history as
perhaps
the best anime or one of the best animes
or just one of the best animated shows
of all time I'm very excited to see
what's in store here because this is
gonna be freaking epic you can just feel
it and yeah so I got a little crush on
Mikasa what are you gonna do I don't
like a strong woman that I would leave
her for Levi any day
something about his coldness I just want
to fix him I want to get gaslighted by
him in a very toxic relationship and try
to get him to emotionally open up maybe
I can fix the guy that's what I do when
I watch attack on Titan I imagine myself
in relationships with all these people
not Eren though he just get kidnapped
hey guys are you excited for attack on
Titan season 4 if you're here you
probably are leave your thoughts down
below make sure to subscribe to the real
rejects click the notification will get
notified whenever got a new youtube
video up let us know in the comment
boxes what other trailers you'd like us
to check out or other videos and whatnot
gonna do my best to see you know like
what's most what are most people
requesting and such or you know vote on
a comment that helps to make sure to hit
that like button last but not least
Katie Ann wanted to show you out today
probably not watching this video so
you'll probably see this a little bit
later we've been talking a lot of
messages lately and I wanted to give you
sincere shout out today because I know
lately you've experiencing quite a heavy
toll there's I mean a lot of us have
worldwide it's been really intense
amongst everything that's already going
on which is affecting everyone and then
some more so than others obviously
you've also experienced a lot of
personal life loss I'm so sorry for
everything that's been happening in your
life as of late but I gotta say though
that even though you've been
experiencing a lot of really troubling
hard difficult times you've also been
someone who's been a very positive force
and an inspiration to be more creative
in my life while you're you know going
through some very difficult times you've
also been someone who has managed to
give me a more uplifting sense that just
goes to show you the kind of heart and
soul that you really do have thank you
and you have a lot of creative outlets
that you do hone in on I'm hoping that
you know as you continue to journal and
whatnot and also with doing poetry that
that could be a great creative outlet
for you right now so I just wanted to
say thank you for being you keep on
fighting the good fight and keep feeling
whatever you got to feel because
or someone who's been very special to me
especially lately keep at it because
you're a beautiful soul thank you